i'm watching msnbc and i don't know this
guy's uh uh you know who he is he's
always on he's a business uh he's on the
business guy business side
and he's interviewing elizabeth warren
yesterday okay and i'm sure you know
what elizabeth warren's stick is you've
heard it and you probably agree with
some of it right where she says you know
elon musk he's this he's a freeloader
you know i don't know if you saw that or
not he was on with uh what's his name
uh uh oh yeah he does the thing with
andrew ross sorkin in the morning you
know who he is
that's cnbc nbc yeah so so anyway so
he's calling around and he says hey so
oh he's a freeload elon musk is a free
loan he says shouldn't we celebrate this
capitalist he's one of us he loves
america he came here he created all
these jobs should we not recognize no he
took money from so what's your position
would warren musk that conversation so
this is the what drives me crazy about
the national conversation none of it
makes any sense so uh
are you for elon musk or against elon
musk wait a minute that question doesn't
make any sense the question is what's
elon musk doing so if you say are you
for tesla well that creates electric
cars and that's going to help to climb
it and i'm in favor of that so that's
great so that's a great thing that that
elon musk is doing but but in terms of
paying taxes for
decades he barely paid any taxes
so wait why would i be in favor of that
billionaires on average right now in
federal taxes pay about eight percent
because of all the loopholes
am i in favor should i like some
progressives will say there shouldn't be
any billionaires i don't agree with that
right so you you did a great job you
built a great business it helped the
world generally you became a billionaire
fantastic right but should you pay your
taxes [ __ ] yeah you should pay your
taxes so no when when elizabeth warren
says they should pay their taxes
otherwise they're a freeloader
she's absolutely right so let's unpack
that let's unpack that okay
so this this takes me to one area where
uh i may have we may have different
opinions but i kind of want to process
it with you so here's here's how i look
at it
if the government has a million dollars
to give to you or to give to the
government on who's going to do better
job with the money
i trust you're probably going to make
the million dollars into 2 million more
than the government's going to turn the
million dollars into two million okay
now you may disagree and you may say pat
i disagree with that but they gave this
guy 464 million dollars
the scanning milan was the freeloader
right
and he takes that 400 million dollars
and
it's a 10-year loan that they give them
he pays it off three years later in 2013
okay with interest at the time he has 6
000 employees he takes it from 6 000
employees to 100 000 employees do you
think that 464 million dollars that he
got from the government that he
borrowed if that was given to somebody
in the government to do you think
they're going to get that kind of return
and produce
94 000 jobs of people in the free market
that taxpayers don't have to pay for so
patrick let me ask him please who gave
him the 464 taxpayers did okay so the
government did so you just made an
argument for the government being
awesome at this
because they gave it to elon musk the
government made the decision to give it
to elon musk and it turned out to be a
great investment but it's
congratulations government but i agree
no but what i'm saying is i agree versus
when we see some of this money when they
say we're gonna do 5.8 trillion dollars
where's the money going to okay so now
let's break it down okay so
uh the government sometimes gives out
subsidies uh that make a lot of sense so
for example when they give to renewable
energies fox news went crazy about
cylinder because that was a that was a
company that lost money but when you
looked at the overall portfolio that was
a thing that obama did really really
well the overall portfolio made tons of
money and gave it back to the government
so that was a success story and so fox
news eventually dropped solyndra because
it was embarrassing because that
government program totally worked on the
other hand some government programs or
actually most government programs are
just built to be robberies okay so
people think oh the people on the left
love the government no it depends what's
the government doing is it invading iraq
then i hate it right is it saying hey
women can't control their bodies then i
hate it it's big government tyrannical
jack-booted thugs coming in telling me
what my wife can do or my daughter can
do [ __ ] off for my life government okay
so what is it what is what's the
government doing so a lot of the
subsidies are just robberies so when you
right now we still give billions of
subsidies to oil companies why they're
the most profitable companies in the
world why are we giving them subsidies
those from 100 years ago when it made
sense
now they don't make any sense at all no
one thinks they make sense they just
like mention
constant subsidies to coal why he owns a
coal company manchester one of the most
corrupt people in congress
so
but they're all corrupt you you name it
or they you talk about hunter biden
orrin hatch's son was a lobbyist who
just rode off his dad right so whatever
he wanted pass he'd go tell his dad and
his dad oh technically we didn't meet at
all it was somebody else from my son's
company lobbying company and they would
pay the sun millions of dollars and then
oran hatch would pass whatever the hell
they wanted so this robbery's been going
on for a long long time so it depends on
what you mean by government yeah i agree
with that where some of the money goes
in places but we don't get the return
but you give a money to a guy like this
who's doing well who brings and makes
money for you and he pays 11 billion
dollars in taxes this year that he's
actually selling some of his stocks
because that's an event that's a tax
event yeah should we not celebrate a guy
like that no when he pays his taxes i
celebrate okay and and you know the
government forced him to do that so he
wasn't going to pay his taxes you know
it was the structure of that particular
i don't know if the government forced
him no it was so patrick that that
particular yeah so there's two different
things that happened in that one it was
the type of stock grant that he had it
was coming due and he had to pay taxes
not he wasn't choosing to sell at that
point but but he did choose to sell a
lot more which i think was him saying
tesla's probably at its peak let me take
some money off the table while
pretending but you see that you see what
happens here then then here's what
happens at this point so what happens
what you just did is there's no way this
guy can ever win with guys like you
never no that's not true but wait a
minute but what you just speculated and
you that's a speculation first part okay
fine i get it like they're forcing to
pay taxes but you say now he's paying
more oh it's probably because he thinks
tesla's at his best so regardless this
is
no no patrick i'll take it i don't care
why he's doing anything i don't care
politician if they're the greatest
should we applaud this guy
so again it depends what are we
applauding him for yeah so patrick in
your example by the way he gets 464
million from the government yep why
didn't the government take equity think
about it if somebody we're all business
people right whose fault is that okay
hold on so if
somebody's gonna give me 464 million
dollars yeah they're gonna take a lot of
equity they're gonna take 99 of that
equity right that's how the markets work
but when the government do does it
they're like oh we got paid back that's
not investing that's not investing why
don't we get equity so you mentioned a
aig we bailed that aig 100 percent of
course absolutely and 13 million dollars
of that was a backdoor bailout to
goldman sachs again that 13 billion
dollars was nothing but a robbery a
goldman sachs took chances in the market
they failed at those chances they should
have been punished by the market for
failing instead the taxpayers bail them
out because of the goddamn corrupt
politicians mainly republicans but yes a
giant portion were democrats and obama
helped in that robbery let's keep it
real now you say when i say that msnbc
loses its mind no
the beloved obama and the beloved biden
and pelosi are perfectly clean get the
[ __ ] out of here so mitch mcconnell
raised a billion dollars so does nancy
pelosi when
mitch mcconnell raised the billion
billionaires like can you believe this
corruption the koch industry's giving
money to mitch mcconnell when pelosi
raises the billion dollars they're like
she's an angel
no they're both bribes our politicians
get bribed on the regular so that those
subsidies to elon musk and a lot of the
renewable energies turned out good for
the country so overall i say i'll take
it but the correct way to structure that
is significant equity for the american
people which they then sell off by the
way but by the way i don't disagree like
let me give you an idea no on the one
part i don't disagree like okay so the
first guy i raised money with for my
insurance company i said uh he says i'll
give you a few million dollars okay
great equity or debt purely debt and it
was a revenue-backed funding debt which
i don't know you know if you know how
that works it's a very
it's a taxing loan that it's a taxing
money you're raising right so ends up
being 33 you're paying per year yeah i
mean so you know how that works right
but you're a startup and you're like
yeah you know okay i'll take it i need
the money we paid him off a year and a
half later the second guy comes around
he says i'm going to give you 10 million
dollars i said 10 million and at this
point i want debt i don't want equity he
says i don't want debt i want equity of
course well that 10 million dollar guy
paid a 40 million dollars so he's
sitting pretty saying [ __ ] can i get
some more so he calls me two weeks ago
he says can i give you another 20
million dollars because i said no no i'm
good at this point we're going to be
totally fine so i get that part that's
the government lack of ability to
negotiate the right contracts for tax
people which you should have asked for
equity in tesla it would have been
better for everybody else can you
imagine how much the government would
have made
equity what a great return would the
government ever do that though actually
get equity in these private businesses
they can for example i think when the
banks all crash they should have
nationalized them in the short term then
gotten equity and then sold them back
into the private market you don't want
the government running
all the private banks that's crazy but
when they go bankrupt you still need the
financial system to function
but when you rescue them as any investor
that rescues a business would have
nearly a hundred percent of it right so
you get so the american people get it so
when when they get back on their feet
and they get to profitable we at least
benefit from that instead what the
american people do is constantly just
give away billions of dollars to
corporations and get nothing in return
why because those corporations gave
millions of dollars in campaign
contributions to those corrupt senators
and and uh representatives yeah so
they're just getting free money because
they're being bribed i i i support the
fact that elon didn't give up equity
good for him because he doesn't want to
be controlled by them that is a choice
that the individual can make sure
whether you want to do that or not the
last thing you want is every time i go
to dmv they treat me like [ __ ] every
time i go to a different institution
that's not run by the government they
treat me better when i was in the army
and i was in the army for a few years it
wasn't like hi mr red david how are you
i was like hey specialist stand over
there like okay i mean that's just not
how things work in free enterprise he
doesn't have to take the money that's
right
he made the right move you always give
the tsa versus clear analogy dude clear
treats you roy hey mr david how are you
how's your day tsa can you stand over
there please sir ma'am i don't care
stand here let me see it it's a very
very so to the the government ran
organizations typically
when you travel do you fly clear or do
you go to tsa pre-check what do you do i
do tsa pre-check i love it i i think
it's perfectly good enough i know other
people unclear love it even more i i
hear you i like both i just want to be
given a little bit of a better service
by a government organization and you
don't get that by government
organizations they treat you like they
own you but it's a very different energy
that you get yeah i i hear you on that
too and sometimes you need private and
sometimes you need public right we can't
uh there's some things like cops
military that we have to have public
that's why the word socialism doesn't
make any sense every economy in the
world is a mixed economy every single
one of them sweden's a mixed economy
we're a mixed economy uh and so some of
it is public it should be public we used
to have private fire departments in
america it was a disaster because every
house would burn down oh he doesn't have
insurance we're not going to put out the
fire
oops there goes a whole block right some
things need to be public including
health insurance so there just needs to
be a perfect balance and mixture there
needs to be a mixture because life is
about balance so saying the government
is bad doesn't make any sense seeing the
government is good doesn't make any
sense the question is what are they
doing and how effectively are they
carrying out that mission if you enjoyed
this short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]
you